Arbor Day is a tree-planting holiday
first celebrated nationwide in our
country and 1872 and April 25th is also
DNA day when Watson Crick Wilkinson
Franklin and their colleagues first
published their findings on the
structure and nature of DNA in 1953 so
today we can combine those celebrations
by planting a clone of the original tree
of Hippocrates and by unveiling for the
first time the gene sequence for the
tree we are in essence through science
returning the tree of Hippocrates to our
campus and also renewing reinvigorating
and preserving the historic living
monument for posterity the tree of
course was given by the ambassador of
Greece in 61 and then planted in 62 and
our institution began business so to
speak in 1962 so National Library of
Medicine in the tree grew up together
under this famous tree in cause in the
island of course where he mentored
practitioners from of his art from
throughout the known world of the time
people of all religions backgrounds and
ethnicities this was if you want the NIH
of the fifth century Hippocrates used to
gather his disciples around him under
the shadow of a plane tree and this tree
lives in this great institution today it
took American ingenuity and dedication
to clone this in a way as I understand
it and have this great dedication again
today the DNA barcode of Life Project
it's a fascinating project for hundreds
and hundreds of thousands of organisms
the goal is to have a physical specimen
from that organism available in a museum
for study and along with it a short DNA
sequence from that organism and this is
very important for conservation efforts
and for basic research dr. Amy Driskell
for from the Smithsonian National Museum
of Natural History downtown took a tiny
DNA sample from the original clone that
we had from 50 years ago and and had
that sequenced so now we know where the
tree of Hippocrates is standing in the
overall tree of life and I think he
would have been very excited about what
DNA comparison and other methods modern
methods are how they're being used to
better understand and ultimately treat
human disease